bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine au
rugby saint quentin en yvelines se
rapproche un peu plus de la montée en
division honneur les hommes de thomas
payen se sont imposés à domicile contre
triel les mureaux une victoire qui leur
permet d'avoir à dix points d'avancé sur
leurs poursuivants nous y reviendrons
dans un instant cyclisme le pistard de
l'équipe de france françois pervis a
réalisé une belle performance ce
week-end en décrochant la médaille
d'argent sur sa spécialité le keirin
nous reviendrons sur ces résultats de
les résultats de me monter dans cette
édition vendée globe laurent boli teint
à louis burton a terminé à une très
belle septième place sur ce tour du
monde en solitaire et sans escale nous
l'avons rencontré à paris la semaine
dernière profite nous débrief sa course
mais avant de développer ces petites
gros plan sur les principaux résultats
du week-end dans le département
on commence ce magazine par la nouvelle
démonstration du sky rugby dans le
championnat de promotion honneur les
saint quentinois leader de la poule ont
réussi à s'extirper du piège tendu par
l'équipe de trial les mureaux l'un des
plus sérieux concurrents pour la montée
le score 27 à 10 le montage est signée
alice deschamps
rien n'arrête le sky rugby dans le
championnat de promotion d'honneur les
saint quentinois leader et grand favori
pour la montée en fin de saison ont
continué leur marche en avant ce
dimanche 19 février contre triel les
mureaux le troisième du championnat
après avoir remporté facilement la
première période 20 5 le sky a maîtrisé
la seconde partie du match pour valider
sa victoire à 27 à 10 h aux grosses
satisfactions par le score non seulement
on marque quatre points au classement
mais trial qui est un concurrent direct
en mai et 0 donc grosse satisfaction
aujourd'hui
autre point positif les saint-quentinois
ont su répondre au défi physique imposé
par leurs adversaires du jour
un match très engagé des deux côtés qui
s'est soldée par trois cartons jaunes
pour chaque équipe
triel les mureaux a également écopé d'un
carton rouge
trial une équipe qui truquent beaucoup
qui à la limite de la règle en
permanence donc du coup c'est difficile
difficile à gérer pour larbi est
difficile à gérer pour nos joueurs donc
à l'arrivée son regard ils ont pris plus
de cartons que nous donc on a gagné le
match de l'indiscipliné faut savoir
répondre dans le jeu des fois on sort un
peu du jeu à savoir se concentrer sur le
ballon et y rester cette victoire permet
au sky rugby de compter dix points
d'avancé sur le second avec seulement
une défaite concédée depuis septembre
une marche suffisamment importante pour
commencer à préparer la saison prochaine
ça a un goût qu'à trois ans ça fait
trois ans qu'on construit trois ans qui
répond bien trois ans qui qui se
construit dans les corps dans les têtes
et l'idée c'est d'aider à présent être
prêt si on remplit notre objectif pour
le championnat honneur qu un championnat
très rugueux comme on a vu aujourd'hui
prochain match le dimanche 26 février
sur le terrain de chilly mazarin le
deuxième du classement l'occasion de
plier définitivement le championnat
on continue avec du rugby mais cette
fois ci nous allons parler du
championnat honneur dans la poule une
versailles a réalisé la belle opération
de cette 12e journée en s'imposant à
domicile au stade de porchefontaine
contre sarcelles le score 18 à 10
au classement les joueurs de la cité
royale prennent la première place du
championnat devant tournant les compte
désormais un point d'avancé sur leurs
poursuivants à noter également la belle
victoire de la vie de la réserve 21 à 20
toujours contre sarcelles
et puis dans le championnat de fédérale
3 plaisir s'est fait plaisir ce week-end
à domicile en s'imposant contre mot
l'équipe qui les avait pourtant dominé
au match aller cette fois ci les
plaisirs aux ont déroulé pour s'imposer
42 à 22 devant une centaine de
spectateurs au classement l'équipe de
plaisir est deuxième derrière son plus
grand rival pour la montée
dans cette poule ris orangis l'équipe
qui compte un match en plus pour leur
prochaine rencontre les joueurs de jean
mi se déplaceront le 5 mars sur le
terrain de houille
il n'y a pas qu'au rugby que les
événements briller à ce week-end en
football l'étoile sportive de trappes a
réalisé une bonne opération sur le plan
comptable dans le championnat de
promotion honneur en s'imposant sur son
terrain contre l'équipe 2 des gobelins
sur le score de 2 buts à 1 au classement
les trappistes sont sixièmes du
championnat avec seulement 4 points de
retard sur la première place détenue par
boulogne billancourt mettra pas deux
matches en retard la montée est donc
toujours accessible un mot de cyclisme à
présent à ce mot de cyclisme sur piste à
présent ligne monta à françois pervis a
réalisé une belle performance à la coupe
du monde à cali le pistard de l'équipe
de france de retour à la compétition six
mois après les jeux olympiques décevants
a décroché ce samedi une belle médaille
d'argent sur le keirin
les biennois noah est devant été devancé
que par le local à zapata en finale on
écoute sa réaction
myst tout le mois de janvier je t elle
sous la route avec ses différentes ma
fédération
mais monaco
j'ai vraiment votre bien et a juré
conservatrice la première fois depuis
les vacances de noël
il ya quinze jours c'était dire là le
départ des fesses par équipes vendredi
c'était dur je leur explosivité et qu'on
est long ce film comme ça comme le kerry
parti je suis julien sports de combat on
va parler de taekwondo dans ce set 8
sport nisrine et bar est de retour en
france la jeunes taekwondoïstes de
trappes étaient partis disputer un open
à las vegas aux états unis fin janvier
afin d'engranger des points pour se
qualifier pour les championnats du monde
la trappiste de 14 ans a finalement
échoué en quarts de finale dans la
catégorie cadette moins de 51 kg on
écoute la jeune prodige au micro de
nicolas d'andria nous raconte son
expérience
c'était très très bien j'étais content
d'avoir participé à sept
us open a même souhaité le niveau était
très élevé le premier combat je les
passais avec un peu de difficulté le
deuxième je me suis inclinée elle est la
fille a été forte
j'aurais pu gagner mais on a la garde
c'était l'événement de ce week-end dans
les yvelines un raid 100 pour 100
étudiants entre la vallée de chevreuse
et rambouillet était organisée par
l'association étudiante centrale supélec
l'événement baptisé saclay nightend et
propose à plus de 400 étudiants un trail
de nuit de 12 km ce vendredi et un
parcours au modulable à vtt ou à pied
autour du château de rambouillet le
samedi en parallèle de la course des
animations multisports avait été mise en
place dans un village sportif on écoute
l'un des organisateurs benjamin boni le
but ça a été de faire un événement qui
sont accessibles à tous aussi bien pour
le niveau sportif que pour que pour
l'ambiance
donc c'est à dire cette fois c'est pour
ça que le nouveau le nouveau format a
été adopté avec des activités dont qui
sont quand même un caractère sportif
mais aussi le village de rambouillet et
c'est une course donc chacun peut faire
les boucles les boucles cliquable qu'ils
veulent et donc vraiment c'est un format
modulable où on peut très bien faire 19
km comme 84 km pour les aides pour les
plus courageux un mot de voile à présent
et du vendée globe la compétition s'est
achevée ce lundi 13 février pour éric
bellion le versailles et nos vies sur ce
tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale est arrivé aux sables d'olonne ce
lundi donc à 17h58 et 20 secondes
pourtant la fin du parcours a été très
compliqué pour les viennois le
navigateur a eu un problème avec sa
grand voile
à cela s'est ajouté des problèmes de
moteur et des vents de face très
puissant le skipper termine finalement à
la 9e place du classement
vendée globe toujours laurent bolitar
louis burton a lui franchi le jeudi 2
février au matin à 8h47 précise la ligne
d'arrivée et termine donc à la 7e place
de cette édition le skipper de bureau
vallée a bouclé son tour du monde pour
la première fois en 87 jours 21h45 avec
une vitesse moyenne de 13 noeuds plus de
trois semaines après son arrivée et nous
avons pu rencontrer à paris cette
yvelinois innu débrief cette course
alors je suis avec eux louis burton le
skipper évinois qui vient de boucler le
vendée globe en 87 jours il est arrivé
le 2 février et il est avec nous ici à
paris parce que voilà les
l'exposition médiatique s'enchaînent ici
suite à votre exploit comment vous
sentez vous depuis votre arrivée
mais je suis passé un petit peu par tous
les états je suis arrivé plutôt fatigués
mais en bonne santé et puis j'ai attrapé
la grippe des coups de fatigue récurrent
du mal à trouver le sommeil
à terme et mais plutôt plutôt en forme
on va parler de tout d'abord de la
course voilà est-ce que les objectifs
ont été remplis finalement vous nous
parliez de 85 jours vous avez fait 87
jours est ce que les objectifs sont
remplis vous avez fini quand même une
très belle septième place
alors c'est vrai que on avait visé entre
85 et 95 jours il ya eu une descente de
l'atlantique sud très compliqué avec des
passages à niveau les bateaux très
récents sont partis un peu par devant
puis après derrière il a fallu se
bagarrer pour décrocher le peloton faire
un peu une échappée et je me suis
retrouvé à partir de l'indien de l'océan
indien
à la 9e place et puis ça s'est
transformé en septième place dans le
pacifique et ensuite j'ai fait toute la
course un peu cavalier seul toute la fin
de course est arrivé aux sables
oui en 87 jours
à 7e place avec ce bateau d'une dizaine
d'années c'est vraiment dans la partie
haute des objectifs donc on est très
content et et grosvalet a fait vraiment
vraiment une belle course c'est vrai
bien soutenu vrai quel est votre
meilleur souvenir en mer vous en rêvez
forcément ouais alors c'est un souvenir
un peu un peu particulier parce qu'ils
les empreintes de pas mal de craintes et
d'inquiétude c'était le passage du cap
horn
puisque je suis passée auprès donc vent
de face dans une météo très compliqué et
c'est vrai que j'ai eu très peur dans
cette zone là et en revanche pas comme
ton on en est sorti et que on est à
nouveau dégager de la terre on met le
clignotant à gauche ont commencé à
rentrer vers la maison voilà ça c'est
c'est un souvenir de joie de fierté de
délivrance enfin il ya vraiment plein de
plein de sentiments mêlés et je crois
que ça restera le vraiment le moment
fort mon vendée globe
maintenant parler du futur vous avez
racheté donc le bateau par bureau vallée
a racheté le bateau du vainqueur du
vendée globe de cette année vous quelle
est votre réaction par rapport à par
rapport à cet achat vous êtes j'imagine
très enthousiastes et prêts à le
l'exploiter au maximum
oui tout à fait en fait on a on a
travaillé avec leurs valets toute
l'année dernière toute l'année 2016 pour
imaginer ce que pourrait être la suite
de notre projet de nos cinq premières
années là en imoca
on a on avait vraiment bien pressenti ce
bateau qui a eu un énorme développement
qui a gagné la transat anglaise qui a
fait deuxième de la jacques vabre
l'année dernière et ben on voit là on
est très content parce que armel a fait
une course superbe avec le bateau s'est
révélé très performant et et l'équipe de
banque populaire travail là actuellement
avec notre équipe de bureau vallée pour
mettre le bateau à l'eau en mars à fin
mars début avril
donc on est très enthousiaste on suit ça
de près il l'a ramené en bon état donc
c'est vraiment de bon augure pour la
suite
merci beaucoup louent burton et à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
merci beaucoup
on continue à parler de voile mais une
échelle plus petite une régate verser
voile radiocommandée était organisée ce
dimanche matin l'île des loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
le rendez vous départemental a réuni une
trentaine de passionnés tous sont venus
avec des bateaux de plus d'un mètre de
haut pour cette compétition sans enjeu
on écoute le président du comité de
course versé au micro de nicolas landry
c'est comme les vrais bateaux on mouille
un parcours donc il ya une ligne de
départ entre deux bouées il ya une bouée
au vent ensuite il ya une bouée sous le
vent ont fait faire deux allers-retours
à au bateau comme comme sur les vrais
bateaux la seule différence est que les
coureurs ne sont pas sur leurs bateaux
ils sont à terre juste à côté des côtés
du parcours ce devait être l'un des
temps forts du sport yvelinois pour le
mois de mars le gala de boxe d'elancourt
vient d'être annulé par les
organisateurs le rendez vous programmé
le samedi 11 mars devait réunir les
grandes têtes d'affiché française de la
discipline dont les boxeurs locaux
d'elancourt marvin petit double champion
de france adil à hamouma dit champion
d'europe des poids super moyens on
écoute leur coach tanguy farruggia nous
l'avons joint par téléphone longueuil le
promoteur et les frileux ils aiment bien
où il va faire le plein partout il
organise depuis le plein il a peur d'eux
après le choc de ce concours j'ai cru
que jouer une équipe qui puisse l'aider
à organiser
on peut le faire on continue par de la
boxe le vert irois ahmed el moussaoui va
remonter sur le ring
un nouveau combat est en préparation
pour le 31 mars ni l'adversaire ni le
lieu n'ont été communiqués mais le
franco marocain devrait selon les
rumeurs combattre au cirque d'hiver de
paris pour grappiller des points pour
les classements ebu nous avons eu le
boxeur par téléphone à la sortie de son
entraînement un combat c'est la fin de
ses études sport merci d'avoir suivi
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]